bonjour mon père me dit fiston
mais en ne s'entend pas
un jour mon père me défie son je te vois
sortir le soir
c'était prévu à ton âge il y a des
choses
un garçon doit savoir
les petites filles tu sais méfie-toi
c'est parce que tu crois elles sont
toutes belles
je veux l'amour
elle boude tout leur fait crois-moi plus
fou belle belle le jour en jour
et puis des filles de plus en plus tu
vas en rencontrer
peut-être même qu'un soir tu oublieras
de rentrer plus t'enverra plus t'en aura
et plus tes comprendra et dans ces
moments tu te souviendras que ton vieux
père
elle te rendra fou de joie de l'armée
crois-moi plus fou même elle le jour un
jour
elle un jour enfin tu la verras tu ne
peux pas te tromper tu voudras lui dire
je t'aime mais tu ne pourras plus parler
avec la veille vous serez unis pour le
pire et le meilleur mais tu tiendras là
le vrai bonheur et aux yeux de ton car
elle
sera que je
veux la
comme
j'ai atteint maman qui lui diras en
l'embrassant belle-mère